mes filles c'est la raison pour laquelle
tu vas avoir droit à l'interview
quelqu'un
[Musique]
bon alors le nom le connaissez darmon le
prénom c'est gérard l'âge 55
voilà comme moi année érotique un
érotique à la taille de quoi non
question ces cas là c'est ty pris 81,80
le poids 75 bravo très bien très bien
conservés gérard darmon comme un de ces
femmes ainsi vous bruno j'ai perdu 15
kilos et vous êtes vraiment vraiment pas
mal et on sait rien c'est le cancer ou
sais c'est le cancer ou c'est agnès qui
vous sert non non non c'est juste que
quand tu te retrouves avec un bide comme
ça tu dis où j'arrête ou je continue moi
j'ai décidé d'arrêter vote à raison de
cette façade va très bien la taille du
sexe gérard je sais que c'est une
question qui vous obsède un petit je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure 80
vous comprenez donc wayana quand des
cartes devant clients ouais on recourt
plus parce qu'il est très heureux mais
il sait pas où la loge et après c'est à
vous gênez non quand même pour parler
mais je l'avais sorti attention et se
déplie là alors sérieusement cette
opération pour doubler la taille de
votre pénis c'est ça s'est bien passé
oui ça c'est on va dire que finalement
ça s'est bien passé c'était compliqué
quand c'était un peu compliqué mais on
passe pas directement de 2,2 de l'anah
l'éléphant comme ça et est alors vos
problèmes d'érection on en reparle plus
l'esprit c'est fini c'est un plus auquel
deuxième quand même oui on était inquiet
je me demande ça a duré quand même 5 6
ans histoire vous est vachement intime
très bien les cheveux ça va ça va mais
c'est une couleur non pas du tout mais
non sur les sursis navré de même bien
cette idée et encore tu verrais ses
couilles pour mon nom mais bon les yeux
alors est ce qu'on peut dire ma fiche là
les cheveux sa couleur les yeux vous
pouvez lire ma chef
une séance amour plus qui se faire
vos films c'est marrant parce que je
trouve meilleure depuis que vous avez
changé de lunettes c'est parce que vous
vous lisez les scénarii maintenant je
dis oui
d'abord il fallait d'abord apprendre la
wii c'est ça il faut apprendre à lire
que j'ai délaissé par une fenêtre et
maintenant je suis là voilà et c'est
comme ça qu'on fait le coeur des hommes
l'année prochaine il les comprend et
encore et encore gerard piqué pas les
jambes un peu lourdes en fin de journée
non ça ça peut m'arriver je me méfie
fait vrai pourquoi kwakwa 5e et 6e 20
mètres 87e
est ce que vous pouvez me tirait la
langue et faire à oui biensur est pas à
l ai pas trop charger soir ça va j'ai
fait quoi hier soir qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait hier soir maison à maison va oui
c'est pour ça il sait 18 chars 10 ans
oui mais auront trempe il est tranquille
goût et ça se voit sur la langue
oui elle est bien rose aujourd'hui
d'habitude les jaune gris bwana fusent
au niveau des cicatrices de la vie vous
en êtes toujours ardemment oui oui
ça va elle sont elles font elles font
pas trop mal être sont bien fermés il y
en a quelques-unes un peu plus sensibles
que d'autres mais tout va bien ça va
j'attendais prochaine et les blessures
intérieures les blessures intérieures
les blessures intérêts vu que ça devient
un peu celui ci victor de la longueur de
la vie n'aurait pas dû voir si les
corrections de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus